banana mark can you guess which outer
banks star liked to venture off into the
wilderness on set
outer banks has become quite the
surprise hit with the first two seasons
topping the netflix charts
it seems like the show's breakout stars
had just as much fun filming the first
two seasons as we did watching them
so break out your surfboards as we dive
into some of the behind the scenes fun
of outer banks that's sarah cameron coop
princess
madeline klein has proved to be the
breakout star of outer banks as john b's
girlfriend and kooks princess
sarah cameron despite her stunning looks
according to klein's co-star madison
bailey
she's much funnier than one would expect
maddie
is just goofy she is just
plain silly bailey went on to gush over
klein's sense of humor
claiming that beneath her model-like
exterior she's just a silly dork on the
inside
she's has a very silly sense of humor
it seems like rudy ponco shares much
more in common with his character jj
than you might expect
madison bailey revealed that panko lives
like he's in an outer banks episode
every waking hour of the day rudy bonko
is an adventure boy something people may
not know is that
in between takes he will often go
explore
things in the woods ponco's co-stars
claim that whenever they're filming
outside he would be climbing trees or
searching for hidden treasure
much like jj despite being the oldest
member of the show's young cast
chase stokes sure likes to clown around
on set when he's not turning on the
charm as teen hero jon b
rudy ponco definitely has some funny and
fond memories of working with stokes
whenever chase is on set and i'm with
him he's usually following some prop
trying and making a joke out of it panko
claims that most of the bloopers from
the series have come from stokes goofing
off on camera
well if stokes and klein are both
goofballs
that must make them a match made in
heaven rudy ponco's claim that jonathan
davis's favorite place on set
when not on camera as the brainy pope
was the craft services table
honestly who could blame him if i could
just go do crap
jd's there picking the fruit snacks and
being like is there anything you know
sprouting
it's almost as if he eats one fruit
snack at a time and then goes back and
grabs another
i think we can all relate rudy ponco has
some great memories of madison bailey
who plays kai
on set for the first two seasons of the
show bayley actually liked to give her
fellow cast and crew some musical
entertainment between takes with her
ukulele skills
bailey if she doesn't have the ukulele
on set she probably like would check her
phone
and then she would then be hashing it
out with like
all of us on set bailey's co-stars
claimed that bayley was so
social that it felt like she was always
talking to somebody on set
while filming season one of the series
nobody on set predicted that season two
would actually happen
so reuniting for season two was a joyous
experience
the feeling of being all back together
was unreal
i mean it was like the instant same
connection as
season one i can't even describe it to
you you'll see it you know
you'll see that way on the screen stokes
went on to call the experience of
reuniting with his co-stars
a dream circumstance oftentimes the
chemistry between two performers can be
so undeniably strong
that it blossoms into real romance that
was the case with madeleine klein and
chase stokes who became an official
couple after filming the first season of
the show
it was just always work oriented for i
mean really till the day we wrapped
stokes says that his relationship with
klein really blossomed while
quarantining with her
despite their relationship stokes claims
that he and klein were able to find a
balance between business and pleasure
we did a good job of like not really
wanting to
though let's be honest for a second
sparks were definitely flying between
them on set as well
jonathan davis recalls that his first
scene he shot with madison bailey on
season two proved to be difficult for
both of them
despite it being an only dialogue driven
scene i went up to an auntie bailey i
just want to let you know that if you
had the call line i sure would have
because my line was right after years
and i had no idea what i was supposed to
say
there's nothing quite like the first day
jitters we're not storing a jail it's
not happening
i'm gonna see what i can do even if i
have to do it by myself one of panko's
absolute favorite moments while on set
for season two was filming the sequence
where jj attempts to break john b out of
jail
operation liberation baby oh boy let's
go
poncho recalls working with director
valerie weiss on the scene that takes
place in the fifth episode
the darkest hour weiss allowed ponco to
help decide on what jj would do during
the scene
telling him that if anything didn't work
she'd tweak it later in the end
weiss never found herself having to
touch up the scene leading to one of the
most memorable moments of the second
season
that was a fun experience i also had a
great time working with chase in that
scene
yeah that was that was a fun one as we
all know the cast of outer banks needed
to stay
fit and active for their roles
especially since their characters are
the definition of outdoorsmen
chase stokes and madeleine klein had to
endure some rigorous workout routines
from treadmills to kickboxing and
swimming in order to have the proper
physique for their characters
i started working out a lot stokes's
personal trainer is alex fine
who actually works with much of the cast
of riverdale
the mail stars on the set of obx season
2 had a rule amongst themselves
commit 100 to the fight scenes in order
to make them look as authentic as
possible
at one point jonathan davis was so
committed to a fight that he
accidentally clipped after drew starkey
who plays rafe
ouch
one of the most interesting aspects of
obx that helps it stand out from other
teen centric shows
is the fact that the cast looks much
more natural rather than the glamorous
aesthetic of the cast
of shows like gossip girl and riverdale
that's because the creative team wanted
the series leads to look sun-kissed and
tanned
that would fit in with the series
southern east coast setting i think
that's just what makes this show so
special
madeleine klein a natural brunette
wasn't too thrilled when she was told
that she had to dye her hair blonde
i had to get really real with myself and
be like do you want to do this
though by the time season 2 came around
klein had taken a liking to her golden
locks that's uh
that's the story of me being blonde for
outer banks
the young cast of outer banks sure
seemed to enjoy their time on set
especially judging from their social
media posts
klein posted a video from the filming of
season 2 where she records
chase stokes madison bailey jonathan
davis and rudy ponco who are
all seen driving in john b's van singing
alt j's indie hit
left hand free this is actually a direct
callback to the opening scene in season
one
the outer banks paradise on earth
nobody on the set of outer banks
expected the series to take off as much
as it did
which meant that there was an immense
amount of pressure felt by the cast and
creative team when season two rolled
around
compared to how they felt while filming
season one and then this year it was a
little different because there were eyes
on it and so i think i definitely put
pressure on myself
at the same time it's still just fun
over the course of filming both seasons
jonathan davis and rudy ponco have
become extremely close
to the point where they've both said
that even without knowing the future of
the show
they still plan on being close friends i
remember saying i would hang out with
this dude
despite anything with the show in fact
some of jd and rudy's banter on set was
recorded without them
even knowing and sometimes it would even
make it into the show
and then we would go back and watch the
show like holy crap like
that's in there now that is chemistry
when we were shooting we just kind of
focused on having fun it truly seems
like the cast of outer banks have formed
a tight-knit bond over the course of
filming the two seasons
from athletic training to improv and
even making true friendships
it makes us happy to know that the cast
of outer banks truly had a blast making
a show we love
what was your favorite moment in season
two